I'm originally from Osaka.
An aikido club was created when I was in junior high school,
that was in 1978,
and one of my teacher had his own Aikido dojo,
so I trained at his dojo too.
After that I went to Kosen,
which is a 5 year technical college and I studied mechanical engineering.
There was no Aikido in my college
so I established a club, and I practiced there for 5 years.
In total, I did Aikido for 7 years in Osaka.
After I graduated in 1985,
I became an uchi deshi at Hombu Dojo,
I was 20 years old at the time.
From the time I started Aikido, I only did that.
Before that, I had done some Kendo in elementary school,
for about 4 years,
but as soon as I started Aikido, I dedicated myself to it.
I had.
During my 3rd year of High School,
I had saved money doing part-time jobs,
and I spent a week at Hombu Dojo during the spring holidays.
So I had trained there before.
GE: You trained there every day...
Yes, every day for a week,
I spent 3 years living at Hombu Dojo.
The life of an uchi deshi involved
getting up at 5:00 a.m.,
preparing tea with Doshu and the Sensei who taught the morning class,
preparing the hot water,
and cleaning the dojo and the office.
We used to finish at around 6:00 a.m.
and at 6:30 a.m., the training started.
The priority in our uchi deshi life at Hombu was training,
from morning to evening.
When there was no training,
we did the chores.
We had to do our own work such as
going to the post office to send the mail,
driving,
and many other tasks like these.
One of our important job was to be Otomo for the Sensei.
We had to carry the Sensei's bags and take ukemi.
That was our main learning experience.
It was occasional,
for example, when a Sensei went to a seminar.
These trips could take a day or longer.
We had to carry the sensei's bag, take care of things, and take ukemi for him.
That included trips inside Japan as well as abroad from time to time.
When abroad, we used to spend about a week with the Sensei.
I also went aborad with Kisshomaru Sensei,
to places such as
Italy twice,
South America,
Brazil, Argentina, and Uruguay.
During my time as Otomo,
I went to Germany too.
Tamura Sensei seemed to have a lot of fun,
but I couldn’t enjoy it much because for me, it was more like a job.
I was so tense all the time so when I was told to go to abroad, I wasn’t too happy about it.
After that, I went with the current Doshu,
as well as Seki Sensei.
We also did a Nihon Budokan group tour,
visiting Australia as a group.
The practice is directed by the Shihan in place
and everybody learns the Shihan’s style.
This is why wherever you go, the practice is a little different.
but still, aikido is aikido, so things we teach are common,
but the teaching method is different,
it depends on teachers.
The ways people who interpret what a sensei teaches are also different,
so, that is okay as it is.
If everybody was the same, it'd be strange.
At that time, Kisshomaru Sensei was the Second Doshu
and the current Doshu was Waka-Sensei.
The old Sensei were in order seniority:
Okumura Sensei, Yamaguchi Sensei, Arikawa Sensei, Tada Sensei...
and there were Ichihashi Sensei, Masuda Sensei,
the senior Sensei,
Watanabe Sensei, Sasaki Sensei,
the senior Sensei of that period...
My Sempai living with me at Hombu were Kobayashi and Sugawara Sensei.
Those who moved in after were Kuribayashi and Kanazawa Sensei.
These were the people I lived with at Hombu.
I didn't have a main Sensei
the uchi deshi must go to the first morning class.
The morning practice of the Hombu Dojo
was Doshu's morning class,
which is the class of the Dojo-cho.
The name of Hombu Dojo used to be Ueshiba Dojo
so it was not like I followed a particular teacher but Doshu was at the center of my practice.
I attended other senseis’ classes to absorb their techniques
so I chose not to have a special Sensei.
That's right,
in my time, we weren't that busy...
We had a bit of time for ourselves.
Nowadays they're quite busy.
They spend more time teaching
but they don't have much time for their own training.
That’s how I feel.
Those who enter Hombu do so to become professionals.
They almost all dedicate themselves to it.
What's most important for an uchi deshi...
most of all...
the ukemi.
I thought of taking good ukemi all the time.
Those who were always called to take ukemi for Kisshomaru Sensei were
Miyamoto, Yokota, and Osawa Sensei,
those 3 were really good.
I was wondering how to become part of that group.
Then, Doshu started using me as uke, and things became even more difficult after that.
When I was uchi deshi, I was only thinking about ukemi.
The fact of working on the technique and becoming a better technician came later.
Well, I spent 10 years at Hombu Dojo,
3 years as an uchi deshi,
and 7 more years living in my own appartment
so in total I spent 10 years at the Tokyo Hombu.
After that came a turning point in my life.
After these 10 years, I wanted to return to teach in Sanda.
I wasn't fired from Hombu!
I'm doing my own style.
I learned from various Sensei
including Saito and Chiba Sensei.
There are also other budo like kenjutsu or iai.
When you watch videos of the founder,
he does taijutsu but he also uses weapons like ken and jo.
He explained the meaning of aikido using weapons, the link between taijutsu and weapons.
I think that's important.
Weapons and taijutsu aren't disconnected.
The basis is the same.
If one wants to understand taijutsu more deeply, one should practice weapons.
I agree with that so we practice weapons in my dojo.
We tend to do whatever style our own teacher is practicing.
When we follow a teacher, we don't have the choice, we must follow what he does.
You would want to know what the teacher is looking for in these practices.
If the Sensei does something like Shinkage-ryu,
when you practice, you remember that,
and after, it may be better to make up your own thing.
There are very few weapons video left in the period of the Asahi newspaper.
During his youth, the founder learned a lot of ken
and from there, it changed little by little later in life at 70 or 80 years-old.
There isn't much footage left from that period.
There is almost nothing left from the Asahi newspaper period.
We must remember that his technique, including his taijutsu, evolved a lot through time.
At the beginning he was throwing very hard but he then got softer in his later years.
He became softer in the same way.
The founder did some Itto-ryu.
There are some old videos and
at the last moment, it ends with a cut.
O Sensei said his partner couldn't understand why he got cut.
The kumitachi of Saito Sensei are all like that of the Itto-ryu cuts.
I do  them too.
Only learning the form makes no sense,
we need to train a lot to understand the meaning of that finishing cut.
Aioi originates from the Hyogo prefecture near Himeji.
There is a shrine there were
the Aioi-No-Matsu grows.
It's a black and a red pine trees that grow together from the same trunk.
It is the same kanji for Aioi.
It symbolizes the strong relationship of a couple.
In my dojo, it represents the relationship between teacher and students.
The students and the teacher study together and grow.
That's the meaning of Aioi.
By chance, it happens to be the name of this neighborhood too [Aioicho], so it's perfect.
GE: But the kanji is different right?
No, it's the same.
GE: Is it?
Yes, the same, the meaning is "to live together".
I'm alone so I can't learn from everybody.
So when I visit a place that has a different style of practice,
I can only show my own thing.
I suggest to do it like that.
"This is my way to do this, please try it"
I don't force them to do my way saying "this has to be like this".
but instead: "you can do it like that too".
For example, in the basics,
even if we consider that there's only one katate dori irimi tenkan,
the movement is done differently by different Sensei.
It's a way to express one's difference.
I don't like the idea of doing strange or complicated techniques to impress others.
I only like to research the basics.
Shomenuchi ikkyo could be different,
every Shihan can do differently, they think differently, they teach differently.
I have my way to do it but it's not exclusive to me.
In iriminage, I explain my way of taking the balance.
It applies in the same way to beginners and Yudansha.
We do different things but we are on the same theme.
There is no need to show flashy things.
To tell you the truth,
we should start seminars by teaching the role of uke.
I can't do it when I travel though.
It's not just about "falling", we need to know until when to stay present,
and hold until the very last minute of tori’s waza.
I can teach that to my own students,
but when I give short seminars, it's more difficult.
This is a bit difficult right?
That's why teaching at some seminars is not very interesting.
Instead of giving one-shot seminars in many places, I try to go to the same places regularly.
I don't teach falls as such
but I give precise instructions during practice such as:
"You let go too early", etc.
What I teach is how to receive the technique, which is ukemi.
Ukemi is something you do to protect your body for safety,
but ukemi is how to receive the technique of the partner. I teach how to take ukemi.
I teach them to hold more,
don’t take uke too fast,
slow is bad, but being too fast is worse.
For example, you take ukemi too fast before your partner even throw you.
When I teach, I take ukemi for my students too.
They can learn how to take ukemi by watching my uke and feeling something by throwing me.
In ken, there is uketachi and uchitachi right?
The Shihan is the one taking ukemi right?
GE: That's right.
It works also in Aikido to a certain degree.
Even though with age, my body starts to ache everywhere,
and I can't take ukemi in the same way, but I can still show how.
When we are an odd number,
I take ukemi to complete the pairs.
I visit groups affiliated with the Aioikai every year,
and I conduct grading examinations
I teach at the same level as here.
I only go once a year
so there are things that don't get through
but in spite of that, I try to make myself understood.
I have been going to some places for over 10 years.
In Russia, it has been only 2 years so there is still a lot of work to do.
They don't understand everything I do
but they realize that 1 seminar per year requires a lot of efforts on their part.
I can only be there for a week so they do their best to learn within that time.
It pleases me very much and makes me want to return there any number of times.
I want to raise the level of the Aioikai
so I need to train some leaders locally.
I want to train instructors who can lead and support them
but right now, we are far from that.
In the one-off seminars, I want to put my personality and my own Aikido forward as much as I can,
I want to present my Aikido to them
and ask them what they think about it.
When I was at Hombu Dojo, Chiba Sensei was living in San Diego.
Occasionally, when he returned to Japan, we practiced together in Kisshomaru Sensei's classes
but it wasn't many.
Yes but not exclusively in the Birankai.
I go to Europe in Poland, which is affiliated to the Birankai.
I go to Bulgaria too...
where else...
different places but not all affiliated to the Birankai.
The first seminar I participated was held about 10 years ago,
it was a course in San Diego
and Doshu went there to discuss about Chiba Sensei's retirement.
I had never learned from Chiba sensei directly, so I thought it would be a great opportunity.
Several people taught in the seminar, including Miyamoto Sensei
and I was asked by Chiba sensei to teach one class there, so I did.
My dojo celebrates its 20 years next year.
At some point, there was a time I got lost in my training. There were things to think about.
At that time, by chance, I came accross a video of Chiba Sensei shot in Nagoya.
It made me want to learn this kind of style.
From that point, I started to work in that direction.
Until that point I had never really talked to Chiba Sensei.
Since I started working on the style,
I have been asked by Chiba sensei to teach Birankai seminars in Europe.
Because of the land prices.
Buying land to set up a dojo in Osaka was expensive
whereas Sanda was more affordable.
It's also closer from the station.
I ended up here by chance.
Tuesday, Thursday, Saturday and Sunday,
about 4 hours per day.
An hour and a half in the morning
In the evening I teach an hour and another one hour and a half without break. So, I teach about 4 hours on average.
In addition to that,
I teach at branch dojos and universities.
She teaches the children's class on Tuesdays.
GE: And she replaces you when you are abroad...
Yes, yes.
She helps here as well as at other branch dojos.
She is there today, she goes on Saturdays and Sundays.
When I'm not here, her and the shidoin, do the teaching.
They probably want to start but in Japan, it's difficult.
Places would be a problem
and salarymen are busy.
Here I have Shidoin examinations every two years.
The Shidoin and Fukushidoin of Aoi receive a certificate.
There is one place that was opened by a man who retired.
But it's difficult.
The most important in Aikido and Budo in general is to keep the beginners mind.
The most important is not to forget the sensations we had when we first entered the dojo,
the feelings we had when we first started Aikido,
the first ukemi we took for our first Sensei...
We shouldn't loose the beginner's mind.
In addition to that, we should also take practice seriously.
I’m not talking about the seminars that only my students attend
but when several different groups come to the seminars, there are something I see there during the class and that makes me think.
There are sometimes people who don't take practice seriously.
Some people try to test their partner,
they try to take strange ukemi.
I dislike this kind of practice.
When we do the technique, we do it seriously.
When we take ukemi, we do it seriously.
We don't hold back, we don't lower our standards.
We must practice seriously and with rigor.
It isn't something that can be taught with words, it is somethign that is shown with the body.
My students see it and feel it from me, so it’s easy to teach here. I do the same when I go to other dojos where I teach regularly.
And also I think "good manners" of Aikido is the basis for everything else and we have to start from that.
I don't do complicated techniques, I usually work on basic techniques.
There are things that come before doing Budo’s "BU".
Like bowing properly when entering a dojo,
and aligning the shoes at the entrance of a Dojo,
You start from a proper place.
Starting from that,
the relationships between Shihan and students becomes important. Relationship with mutual trust.
It should not be one direction only.
When we get to know each other more, trust and a mutual respect take place, and we can delve more deeply into each other.